those are bright lights
my name is Jared there's my daughter
Flynn I guess I'm gonna be trying some
stand-up this week thank you
hi I'm Ari and this is my dad hi I'm
Cedric he does do a lot of dad jokes
that we started calling groaners because
they're so bad they make you groan no I
am not done comedy I've seen a lot of
comedy entertained the notion once I
wrote a page down and I threw it out it
was terrible
do I think I'm funny even a broken clock
is Right twice a day so I guess yeah I
guess I hit it every once in a while she
liked that lawyer please are you sure
funny I thought I had a week how am I
gonna do this whilst having a job as
being a father see how hard this is
nervous about it action might one have a
medic standing by stairs I got 72 hours
to write a five-minute set okay and you
need dad dude what do you say when you
meet a deer with no eyes what do you
think I have no idea your dad is proud
of that I just wrote on my material last
night and this is like tomorrow and I'll
be amongst some seasoned comedians who
probably gonna kill it so I'm gonna do
my set for my family my wife didn't know
if she was gonna be a good mother
how are you supposed to know if you're
gonna be alone but but as soon as the
baby fell out and the baby did fall out
my wife wanted the baby out and baby
fellas yes I didn't hook up this article
blood basically it says six ways not to
suck understand entertain my favorite
reading that you know I got it in all of
us we're still really nervous but I
walked around the block kind of
rehearsing my set in my head and that
made a little easier right now I am just
kind of like writing down key elements
from mine just so I can try to remember
it better I'll probably bring it on a
stage just so I don't get lost no in
life the rewards go to those that are in
the arena fighting so if I get up there
having never done something like this
just the act of trying I've got
something to feel good about I am a
little nervous about the show there
might be long pauses and it's gonna be
kind of awkward but I got a plan for
that lot could go wrong
jokes might not land I might just forget
stuff I'm not ready I've made a mistake
I will regret everything
[Applause]
all right
those are bright lights just a shout-out
to everyone out here you're all a
beautiful crowd yeah something you know
that this is really a really interesting
experience I'm getting a little
lightheaded
it's uh I guess that's part of the whole
stand-up experience nominative
determinism anyone ever heard of that
one I had no idea what it was I had to
look it up anyway really quick it's the
hypothesis that your name influences
your life choices so you know like if
you're you know your name is see more
skin more you'll probably end up
becoming a dermatologist you know like
the anesthesiologist doctor dr. feelgood
off in the sleep right some low-hanging
fruit there the another one is you know
like dr. Bowen well would be a
chiropractor right oops that could also
be something else fitting it well you
ever just look at someone and you you
you're pretty sure but you're not sure
you don't want to ask because it might
be racist like if they're a ninja like
well I found out like a good way to
figure out if someone's a ninja he's
just like throw a knife at their face
and if they catch it oh [ __ ] that dudes
a ninja if they don't used to have
someone in the face but if you think
someone's a ninja they're probably a
ninja you know uh yep you know I am my
wife didn't like that joke guys yep she
also didn't know whether or not should
be a good mom but when the baby fell out
her maternal instincts kicked in she's a
great mom and I think my paternal
instincts kicked in too I became very
protective and I immediately regretted
not knowing a martial art because
they're all those ninjas out there you
know they're dangerous
like even not just the Asian ones like
American ninjas might be more dangerous
cousin white privilege blacked out yeah
I got a little lightheaded there for a
moment yeah I'd probably do this again I
I was thinking about my performance real
in relationship to the actual comedians
who were very professional they were
really really good yeah so it made me
realize I had a long way to go but it's
kind of inspired actually you know so
who knows maybe I would do something
like this again I'm not gonna do it I'm
not gonna be a stand-up you don't have
to worry we're gonna worry about that so
I just saw my dad before him and I think
he did a really good job
[Music]